[Music]
foreign
just gonna turn a whole family into
millionaires
should I have a fashion line a
foundation
[Music]
you were incredible today thank you I
mean it wasn't even like tennis it was
an entirely different case
hey come hang out with us later let me
come tuck you in no we just keep talking
I come home
how often does this happen going after
the same girl not as often as you think
we usually have different types so
you're saying I should be flattered
aren't you everybody's type
which one of us
[Music]
he's not in love with you what makes you
think I want someone to be in love with
me it's nice to see lit up about
something even if it's my girlfriend
Art's got his coach Tashi Donaldson who
also is his wife I'm playing for both of
us Tashi
I think maybe we're disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in a salon
like me when we were teenagers when we
were teenagers hey I love you
I know
you don't know what tennis is
it's a relationship
we went somewhere really beautiful
together
I'm taking such good care of my little
white boys
I assume you planned this not this part
[Music]